foreign
Dave Chappelle celebrated his 50th
birthday last week in front of a sold
out crowd at Madison Square Garden but
the comedian was far from alone on stage
the guest list from that night might be
one of the craziest lineups in MSG
history including Shane Gillis Jeff Ross
Aziz Ansari Donna Rawlings Chris Rock
and Pete Davidson to open the show as
well as musical acts like John Mayer
Burna Boy and Travis Scott who just
released a song featuring Dave Chappelle
on his new album Utopia Dave used his
legendary voice to do voice over for the
song Paracel which debuted at number 53
on the Billboard top 100 marking Dave
Chappelle's first and only appearance on
that list Cactus Jack pulled up to MSG
to help celebrate Dave Chappelle turning
50 years old and led the audience in
singing Happy Birthday
happy
[Applause]
it's safe to say every comedy fan in
attendance that night got the maximum
bang for their Buck but this also has to
be an all-time sick experience from
Shane gills's perspective who not only
has a tremendous amount of respect for
Dave Chappelle in the first place and
Performing during his birthday party at
Madison Square Garden is a huge honor
but also as a big fan of rap music
meeting Travis Scott must have been
unreal what uh what what did your
Spotify rap look like who are you
listening yeah that's embarrassing oh
actually it's always Drake's been number
one
Drake Kanye Mac Miller ASAP Rocky
and I forget the other one that's
[__] sick yeah I was proud I was
proud yeah it's right ASAP and Mac
Miller yeah Mac Miller's great damn bro
I didn't people didn't know you're
[__] listening to the ASAP do people
know that I don't know now they know
what I like to do is do stand up get
hammered and then listen to motivating
rap oh [__] it on the Uber home looking
over the skyline
when I wake up go what the [__] was I
doing last night oh no oh [__] I'm a
[__] loser you're all gonna be really
bad again outside of all the celebrity
rappers hanging out backstage and Mike
Tyson sitting in the front row the
actual lineup of comedians for this show
at MSG was stacked to the brim imagine
buying tickets to see Dave Chappelle at
a historic venue like Madison Square
Garden which is already going to be dope
in the first place and then once you get
there realizing you also are about to
see Shane Gillis Jeff Ross Chris Rock
and Aziz Ansari all perform back to back
on the same night all right this guy I'm
bringing on stage is so funny he got
canceled at the beginning of his career
oh
please welcome from almost Saturday
Night Live changes
Dave Chappelle sold out four shows at
the Garden in the nights leading up to
his birthday and even through a private
party at The Comedy Cellar the following
night where even more stars came out
including Justin Timberlake Chance the
Rapper Andrew Schultz and many many more
it would have been nice to hear Shane
talk about all the small details of this
story from his perspective on the
podcast last week I'm sure some
hilarious [__] was happening behind the
scenes but the young bull was across the
pond in Ireland last week watching Notre
Dame's season opener and was not on Matt
and Shane's latest episode however was
Shane's new special set to come out next
week there is a chance we'll get a run
of Shane Gillis guest appearances on
various podcasts soon speaking of which
guest spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Dave Smith and Hulk
Hogan two bears one cave was Burton
Tom's 200th episode kill Tony this week
was a massive episode with Joe Rogan
post Malone and Kurt Metzger why made
should not have a guest flagrant had on
Max Holloway we might be drunk out on
Jared freed Matt and Shane's secret
podcast featured Tim butterley Naim Ali
and Matt no Shane are you garbage was
with Kyle Dunnigan Doug Smith was on
stavy's world taste buds battled eggs
benedict vs pancakes with Josh Nasser
Mark Normand went on the Giannis
papasauer as well as whiskey Ginger they
were kind of hippies who went to the
Army to uh get like see the world they
didn't care about war they hated War
they hated fighting they hated guns but
they're like yeah we'll get a check and
we'll see the world that's actually
really smart that's like Ari shaffir
that's basically what he is yeah yeah
he's the idea of my mom like doing
push-ups for a drill sergeant is insane
he took rocks on and red glasses you
know it's a short gray hair really so
the idea of her being like GI janing it
is insane to me but keep my wife's name
out of your [__] mouth okay my wife
I talk about a [__] bounce back man
amazing he's great he's fine dude you
think no one cares he's crying on camera
everything I'm so sorry I think no one
cares he came out with that movie what
was that movie he was a slave movie yeah
you you directed that didn't you yeah so
much experience I mean how could they
pick from somebody who hasn't done it
before right well you gotta get Norman
Will Smith's used to backlash
this past weekend with the Yvonne talked
to a coroner the Box podcast had on
Maria Bamford Mike Feeney was on the
Honeydew Danny Brown was on first date
Lauren Compton was on hey babe Conrad
Vernon was on the Harland Highway Being
Ian with Jordan live feature Dave Attell
Big Jay oakerson and Brendan sagalo Paul
verzi was on you know what dude slushy
was a guest on Chrissy chaos tigerbelly
had on Gary Owen and episode one of the
Kim Kong didn't take over was with Jorge
mazvidal as far as new stand-up specials
are either out right now or coming out
soon Joe list enough for everybody came
out last week marking Joe's Third
special in three years I was hanging out
I have a since she's 10 years old and
then we were hanging out and
um she had they have a family dog and
the dog's name is Penny and she said she
went come here Penny and then she turned
to me and she said I'm trying to teach
the dog to come
yeah you guys are laughing already
that's funny
I thought it was funny also
because come
which by the way she's a child I want
you to know I wasn't like
whoa sicko you know I just I kept a
straight face
but I wanted to be like choke it a
little and be patient you know
I had that locked and loaded
cause I'm fun Adam Ray released a 38
minute comedy special on his channel
titled live from Portland and Todd Berry
domestic Shorthair came out yesterday on
the all things Comedy Channel we also
had 30 minutes with Kurt Metzger
Premiere earlier today on YouTube one
week after gas digital presented 30
minutes with Dave Smith that sucks with
me the fact that rappers meet with
presidents
but that's where we're at now America
rappers meet with presidents Kanye met
with Trump cardi B went to the White
House and met with Joe Biden yeah that
happened
before Trump common and Jay-Z both went
to the White House and they met with
Barack Obama that's where we're at as a
country rappers meet with presidents and
then the president is like what do you
think I should do
and the rappers like we'll buckle up
because I have a lot of ideas
and the president's like thank God I am
fresh out of ideas I have no clue what
I'm doing here there's also a few
specials that will be coming out
relatively soon the big news is Shane
Gillis releasing his first Netflix
special next week September 5th the
special will be titled beautiful dogs
and is one of the most highly
anticipated comedy specials of the year
with some fans who've seen this set Live
on tour even predicting it could beat
live in Austin for Shane's best work
speaking of upcoming specials that have
been filmed but not yet uploaded Tony
Hinchcliffe taped his new special
Saturday night in Atlanta and shared
this picture on Instagram saying quote
it was magical can't wait for y'all to
see it we got the best podcast moments
of August coming out later this week
right here on this channel joke world
this past month featured a lot of funny
moments in the comedy world so this
video should be pretty good if you don't
want to miss it consider subscribing to
joke world right now I promise it's
worth it and if you're already subbed
looking for even more content from the
comedy World feel free to give our
second Channel a try Lincoln bio thanks
for watching
[Music]
world of wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out